the White House has released its
Christmas video and a lot of people are
saying it's cringe it's creepy and it
looks like the Hunger Games but I don't
care too much about that I mean if
they're going to put out a bad piece of
art well you know people do that all the
time but it turns out the group behind
it is actually a racist organization
whose uh uh uh pred their their mission
is predicated upon racism it's actually
kind of interesting the White House
chose to choose a racist hate group is
what many people are saying and it is
true their website is loaded with an uh
with racist propaganda and things of
that sort so I I I I can I figure we're
getting so close to Christmas let's talk
about what we are doing here with these
uh uh holidays but we do have a bunch of
other news Hunter Biden is telling
people he may have to flee the country
if Donald Trump is elected oh boy and
then we got a bunch of other silly news
we'll get into a lot um Mickey Mouse as
of January 1 will be public domain